well don't check your 401k balance
tonight because the stock market just
had one of its worst days in months
investors were reacting to a speech from
fed chairman jerome powell who said he's
committed to fighting inflation no
matter what have a look reducing
inflation is likely to require a
sustained period of below trend growth
moreover there will very likely be some
softening of labor market conditions
while higher interest rates slower
growth and softer labor market
conditions will bring down inflation
they will also bring some pain to
households and businesses
these are the unfortunate costs of
reducing inflation
but a failure to restore price stability
would mean far greater pain
now
one thing is certainly not going to help
inflation is biden's student debt relief
scam and now congressional republicans
are speaking out demanding nancy pelosi
stand up to biden and remind him as she
herself once said
that he does not have the power to
unilaterally cancel student debt
here now with more our florida
congressman byron donalds and fox
business contributor phil flynn uh
gentlemen thanks for joining us
congressman i want to start with you
because
um
raising taxes throwing hundreds of
billions of dollars uh that it really
getting after inflation is it
no it's actually going to cause more
inflation but the problem is that joe
biden and the democrats have nothing
else to run on because the only way to
really fix america is to reverse course
on all of their crazy policies so how
can you run for election in a couple of
months while reversing course on your
agenda to actually fix the country it
doesn't work so they're going to double
down and they're going to triple down
it's going to cause more harm and it's
about time that secretary powell acts
chairman powell excuse me actually came
out and started admitting what everybody
else knows this is this is going to get
much worse if we don't raise interest
rates strength strangle this inflation
but on capitol hill we have to stop the
insanity
yeah
it takes some discipline uh but in a an
election year and it seems like it's
always an election year congress uh and
certainly the white house never seems to
be able to do that phil you saw the fed
chairman's comments the inflation
reduction act what's your take on all
this
you know my take is is uh
fed chairman powell basically said
listen to the american people you're
gonna have to take a lot of pain you may
lose your job
because of the bad policies we made in
washington that's what he said very
clearly it's obvious that the biden
administration policies have added to
inflation you know they can blame
vladimir putin you know they can say
it's transitory but this record amount
of spending and once again this college
spending bill that that is even more
inflationary and causes more problems
down the road it's causing more economic
pain for the average americans in a lot
of average americans you know couldn't
even get a loan to go to college yet but
they might have to work to pay off other
people's loans um and so that's a very
bad thing and the main reason that the
biden administration said well you know
the cost of college has gone up and
federal grants haven't kept pace the
question is why are college prices going
up faster than inflation i think the
biden administration is trying to make
more inflation to keep up with college
costs i guess
yeah
it is uh crazy times look uh the the
left is going to be galvanized on the
roe v wade issue um we've seen that
playing out uh congressman what is going
to be the the the call for republicans
to get out the vote uh come november
oh man i got a laundry list number one
actually securing the border and
stopping fentanyl from killing kids and
people in the united states number two
actually having a sound spending
strategy to curtail inflation and get
our fiscal house in order number three
actually having some real strategies
with respect to the oil markets in the
united states the energy framework in
the united states that can actually
bring to bring cheap fuel for the
american people number four actually
having real investigations and holding
this administration accountable because
every american knows whether you're a
republican a democrat an independent
this president and this administration
is failing you and republicans are the
only ones that are going to hold joe
biden accountable
fiscal discipline limited government
accountability and a strong national
defense i think that's the key adhere to
the constitution congressman i i think
you're right and phil flynn uh thank you
both for joining us tonight on hannity
hey sean hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to fox news youtube page and
catch our hottest interviews and most
compelling analysis you will not get it
anywhere else